[Music]
the mcu
keeps growing not only on the big screen
but especially on disney plus
one of the next big hits in marvel
series lineup will be hawkeye
as has been known for several days the
series will be available on disney plus
from november 24th
and will include eight episodes which
will then be released weekly
in addition to the announcement of the
release date a first image was shared by
twitter featuring clint barton and his
protege kate bishop
she is undergoing training to follow in
her mentor clint's footsteps as hawkeye
in an interview with entertainment
weekly lead actor jeremy renner further
adds that kate is a huge fan of clint
but despite her enthusiasm she does
bring some problems to her role model's
life
among other things this series revolves
around the temporary loss of his family
due to the events of infinity war and
ant game
as well as kate's not always easy
existence as a candidate for the hawkeye
title
we are excited about the final adaption
of the marvel series which will be
available on disney plus from november
24th 2021
recently actor dwayne johnson officially
announced his exit from the upcoming two
fast and furious movies tenant
11. after several arguments with vin
diesel and poor prospects for
reconciliation the 49 year old decided
to turn his back on the main series
till the end some still believe that it
must be somehow possible to bring back
luke hopps this optimism was now finally
shattered however because
johnson's colleague karen garcia urged
fans to bury their hopes for good in an
interview with collider
nevertheless they don't have to bid
farewell completely as they're currently
working on a sequel to the spin-off hops
and shaw
like the original the sequel will stand
on its own and according to garcia will
certainly please the fans
a good compromise for fans of the main
series and the character luke hopps
at the moment it is not yet certain how
exactly fast and furious 1011 and hops
and shot 2
will continue or when they will be
released there's more news about dwayne
johnson from his other movie
jungle cruise although the blockbuster
which had a budget of 200 million us
dollars only earn 62 million us dollars
at the box office his sequel may well be
in the works soon
johnson himself announced this on his
twitter account so
those responsible will sit down this
weekend to plan a potential sequel
that's not at all surprising since in
spite of the financial losses
it's also a pretty strong argument for a
sequel the film's ratings
appropriately johnson posted a tweet
confirming that jungle cruise is the
highest rated film of his career on
rotten tomatoes
sure there are some fans who didn't like
the film as much but on the whole
the flick seems to deliver what it
promises which is to be a
well-made family adventure
hollywood legend sylvester stallone has
been in the movie business for an
incredible 52 years in the last 10 years
there has been at least one film with
his contribution in theaters in almost
every year not bad for a now 75 year old
but it seems like the rocky star
still hasn't had enough at the end of
july the actor surprisingly posted a
picture with a new ring of the
expandables leader barney ross which he
himself impersonates
the design is said to be finished so far
which in turn implies that the
expandables 4
first announced in 2016 is still being
worked upon
it is quite possible that stallone will
be celebrating his farewell to the movie
business with this film
similar to what he has already done with
rocky and rambo
unfortunately the exact cast of the
action blockbuster and the expected
release date for expandables 4
have not been announced as of yet
amazon's most expensive series of all
time has been in production for some
time now
namely the lord of the rings after peter
jackson's film trilogy
and the hobbit spin-off fans are already
eagerly awaiting the giant project
since we must still wait quite a while
until the official release on september
2nd
2022 we're all the more pleased that the
first image from the series has now been
published you can see a scene from the
first episode which offers
plenty of speculation for instance you
can see the two trees
of valinor in the background under the
strong radians as
is well known the first age of middle
earth was initiated with the creation of
the two trees lorelei and telperion by
the velar
the huge trees once served as a source
of light and were destroyed by melchor
who later become also known as morgoth
he was the most powerful of all velar
and also the mentor of the later villain
sauron
the question is what did this tell us
about the plot we assume that the
episode starts at the end of the first
age and deals with the destruction of
the trees subsequently
we would then arrive at the second age
in which the series is supposed to take
place
there are many indications that that is
a valar or an elf or
otherwise no one would be allowed to
live on the continent of amman where the
land of the valar is located in this
context
one could also conclude that the
magnificent city on the scene represents
velmar
as you can see although only one image
has been revealed the storylines are
already starting to come together we
hope for more footage
and we'll keep you up to date as always
it should not have escaped anyone's
notice that the legal matter between
amber hurt and johnny depp is still
being fought with no
holds barred after johnny dam has so far
struggled against devastating financial
losses and defamation on a grand scale
a new campaign against his ex-wife is
now getting underway
in recent days and weeks calls for her
to be fired from the aquaman sequel have
been accumulating
producer peter saffron however doesn't
give in to the demands of the fans and
stands up for the 35
year old he made it clear that there is
no need to respond to such demands and
certainly
not to defer to the wishes of johnny
depp fans the situation is different for
the idol
after all the marital feud cost the 50
year old his long-term plan engagement
and fantastic beasts
in spite of this death was able to win a
small victory in this war as
amber heard wanted to donate the 7
million us dollars she received after
the divorce but
presumably did not so a recipient of the
money children's hospital in los angeles
must now disclose whether it actually
received the donation from her that was
agreed upon in advance
thus it remains unclear which of the two
is closer to the truth and who will
ultimately emerge as the winner if there
is such a thing at all however one point
is already certain
johnny depp's career on the big screen
has definitely seen better days
the first marvel movie from the fourth
phase black widow has barely been
released and
already there's a lot of turmoil behind
the scenes the reason for this is the
release policy of the streaming service
disney plus which is causing the actors
massive financial losses this is also
the case for scholar johansen who has
filed a lawsuit against a former
employer according to the wall street
journal
the accusation breach of contract on the
part of the movie giant
allegedly on paper it states that black
widow will receive an exclusive
theatrical release
it further states that johannes has a
share in the worldwide box office takens
meaning that these account at least for
a significant
part of her final fee given that the
film was released in theaters alongside
a vip access on disney plus however
the actress feels she is at a
disadvantage the theatrical release of
the marvel blockbuster initially ran to
the full satisfaction of all involved
with 158 million us dollars in sales on
the first weekend
but crashed a week later with an
internal all-time low for disney there
are many explanations but the most
decisive of them is certainly the
parallel release on disney plus which
generated another 60 million on the
first weekend in addition to all the
theatrical revenue of these 60 million
however
not ascent will go to johansen and the
already shaken cinema operators as the
profit goes straight
to disney in an official statement the
company relativizes the action and even
calls the lawsuit devastating in view of
the still prevailing pandemic
it will be exciting to see how the
verdict in the case of johansson against
disney will turn
out after all a decision in favor of
johansen could trigger a veritable surge
of similar lawsuits
in recent weeks we have often reported
on merchandise leaks and numerous other
rumors regarding spider-man no way home
but one important marketing component is
still missing from the most anticipated
movie of 2021
an actual trailer indeed a trailer that
confirms or at least doesn't debunk
all the rumors that have been
circulating of course this includes the
almost certain appearance of tom holland
andrew garfield and toby maguire in
their respective spider-man roles
however
the operative word is still almost
because nothing has been confirmed or
denied by official sources so far
there's also the mystery of spidey suits
after all the leaked suits of the
superhero reveal clues to new magical
powers that surely originate from dr
strange's mind
her last but not least a secretly
recorded set image has been circulating
for a few days now showing not only the
sanctum sanctorum and doctor strange
himself
but also a feast truck in the background
those who are familiar with the
spider-man universe will surely know
this organization as
after all this stands for food emergency
aid shelter and training
and is actively supported by peers on
may this organization has a less
pleasant reputation in the comics since
there it is founded and run by martin
lee and
merely serves as a cover for the
gangster boss under his ville name mr
negative
he has powerful abilities like the use
of light force and dark force
so much for some of the rumors that have
been popping up in recent weeks and
months we keep getting comments with the
following question when is the no way
home trailer finally coming
and that's the question we will try to
answer for you today
no way home will be released in theaters
in december and with just under 4 months
to go we have only seen a logo
and a small teaser of the movie's name
for such a mega blockbuster
this is extremely unusual there has also
been no trailer release for matching
theatrical releases of blockbusters like
black widow and the suicide squad this
raises the obvious question
what on earth are sony and marvel
waiting for many people thought after
the spectacular season finale of loki at
the beginning of the multiverse chaos a
few weeks ago
that now was the right time to unveil
the trailer
we got the clarification as to how the
clash of the three spider-man can happen
and how villains from
other dimensions can target the
protagonist yet
even that doesn't bring sony out of its
shell many fans have already been
worrying whether sony will release a
trailer for the film
at all leaving us in the dark until the
film's theatrical release on december
17th or even that the movie might be
postponed again leaving us with no
footage yet to be
seen at least we can reassure you about
the former
the last part of the tom holland trilogy
is the biggest release for sony since
the beginning of the pandemic
so of course they want to make sure that
moviegoers who aren't part of the
fanbase will
also go to theaters to see it and for
that they need promising
looking trailers and tv spots we
consider another movie post moment
rather
unlikely due to the film's systematic
connections with numerous other mcu
projects such as doctors range 2 but
unfortunately it isn't out of the
question due to the ongoing situation
the latest venom 2 trellis still lacks a
concrete theatrical release date only
referring to fall 2021
that seems to point to another delay
however the film could also be postponed
by just a few weeks for example
and start in october or early november
instead of september
in that case there would be no impact on
the cinema release of spider-man
no way home we assume that sony is
currently using countless rumors and
leaks and the resulting speculation
within the online community to build up
further hype for the film with
practically
no financial effort we should finally
get to see a proper trailer for the film
in mid or late september at the latest
before the current theatrical release of
venom 2.
in fact maybe there will even be an
exclusive
sneak peek before the screenings of
venom 2. from a marketing standpoint
that would definitely make sense
in addition it should then be clear
whether the current situation allows for
a cinema release in december
at any rate it remains exciting and we
can hardly wait to finally see a full
trailer for the upcoming
spider-man no way home that's it for our
little special on this occasion
subscribe to our channel if you liked
the video and activate the notification
bell on the channel page
to make sure you don't miss the trailer
in the end you never know when the time
will come
[Music]
foreign